dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à monsieur pierre charon
pour 15 minutes
je suis le président monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues j'aurais pu commencer cette
intervention par le récit de ces faits
divers qui illustre malheureusement
quotidiennement la terrible situation de
notre pays mais louis l'a fait
avec beaucoup de talent et beaucoup
d'émotion j'ai donc consacrer mon propos
sur cette ppl que le vous proposons
aujourd'hui mais il est important malgré
tout de situer ce texte dans un contexte
d'hyper violence à laquelle nos forces
de l'ordre doivent répondre et qu'elles
doivent contenir une nouvelle violence
dont les acteurs sont chaque jour plus
lourdement armés quand j'étais
adolescent les blousons noirs avaient
des canifs et les chaînes de vélo
aujourd'hui ces délinquants ont troqué
ses canif contre des kalachnikovs or
très régulièrement nous sommes témoins
situation terrible où un policier ou un
gendarme perd la vie dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions certains parleront sans
doute des risques du métier
effectivement c'est là toute la
particularité de l'engagement dans la
police ou dans l'armée de risquer sa vie
pour protéger celle des autres mais
cette particularité de nous inspirer le
plus profond respect
la plus profonde gratitude en aucun cas
de la moquerie ou du dédain ce sont
chaque année plus de dix mille policiers
qui sont blessés soit une quarantaine
par jour le cardo juridique ne semblent
plus adaptés à cette situation et c'est
pourquoi nous avons conjointement décidé
avec louis et une quarantaine de
sénateurs de déposer cette proposition
de loi ce texte a une portée symbolique
est une nécessité concrète une portée
symbolique tout d'abord en ce qui
confirme le monopole de la violence
légitime pour reprendre la formule du
sociologue max weber monopole qui
fondent l'état de droit
permettez moi mes chers collègues de
prendre ici le temps d'ouvrir une
parenthèse sur la nature de cet état de
droit si chère à nos démocraties
contemporaines
l'état de droit se fonde sur deux socles
le monopole de la violence légitime qui
justifie la prérogative de l'état en
matière de maintien de l'ordre et le
respect des libertés civiles qui
implique un usage exclusivement défensif
de la violence si l'on n'oublie l'un des
ces deux socles la la société bascule
soit dans l'anarchie des règlements de
compte soit dans l'état totalitaire qui
étouffe la liberté sous la répression
policière dans les deux cas l'oubli de
cet équilibre crée une situation
dangereuse si l'état n'a plus le
monopole de la violence légitime celle
escalade anarchique des milices et des
gangs c'est la société du désordre du
tous contre tous où la loi du plus fort
remplace la loi du juste et si l'état ne
limite pas son autorité c'est l'escaladé
de la répression
l'assèchement de la liberté est bien
souvent la révolte d'un peuple contre un
autre c'est ainsi dans un souci
permanent équilibre que nous avons bâti
cette proposition de loi afin de donner
toute leur légitimité et leur place à
nos forces de l'ordre tout en respectant
les règles les plus fondamentales des
limites de l'autorité dans une
démocratie moderne nous avons dû
élaborer ce texte en veillant à tenir
deux fils celui des policiers qui voient
leurs conditions de travail se dégrader
chaque jour et qui attendent de la part
du législateur une réponse concrète à ce
problème est le fils de la vigilance à
ce que ce texte soit en aucun cas une
incitation pour les policiers à tirer à
la première occasion ce travail exige
une certaine finesse et les frontières
sont bien entendu très ténu mais quand
il s'agit d'une question aussi
essentielle que le maintien de la paix
civile nous ne pouvons pas
systématiquement nous réfugier derrière
la complicité du droit
si nous voulons vivre ensemble et vivre
en paix il faut qu'il y ait un ordre et
des forces qui le fasse respecter
or comme le développer à l'instant mon
collègue louis contrairement aux
gendarmes et aux douaniers qui peuvent
faire usage de leurs armes à feu après
les sommations et dans des conditions
limitatives les policiers ne sont
autorisés à ouvrir le feu quand réponse
est une agression de même nature cette
situation met donc quasiment sur le même
plan les délinquants et les forces de
police c'est tout simplement moralement
inadmissible et il est urgent de faire
évoluer le droit afin de l'adapter à une
réalité qui a changé notre proposition
consiste ainsi à donner aux possibilités
la police ni la possibilité pendant
policiers de faire usage de leurs armes
dans un cadre légal et protecteur des
forces de l'ordre et sous réserve de
certaines conditions limitatives dans un
état de droit si les délinquants
bénéficient de la présomption
d'innocence
il est légitime que les forces de police
bénéficie de la présomption de légitime
défense en dans l'état actuel du droit
il faut quasiment que le policier se
soit déjà fait tirer dessus pour pouvoir
utiliser son arme la réalité des
situations et souvent beaucoup plus
complexe que les classements ce
arbitraire validant ou non la légitime
défense
je vais vous donner un exemple afin de
bien comprendre ce qui se passe sur le
terrain un policier poursuit un individu
porteur d'un pistolet celui-ci à 20
mètres du policier se retourne et
menaces se garnit de son arme
lequel fait usage de la sienne à trois
reprises
l'individu est tué et le toque ci
démontre que la balle a frappé le dos
alors que le policier affirme avoir tiré
sur un individu qui menaçait légalement
la balle ayant frappé l'individu de dos
celui ci ne pouvait diriger
simultanément son arme en direction du
policier l'agility mme défense est donc
exclue
cet individu qui s'enfuit en tenant un
pistolet à la main présentait pourtant
un danger important pour les policiers
et les passants on peut imaginer qu
entre le premier et le troisième coup de
feu tiré par le policier
l'individu ciré tourner un micro
instants pour se cacher et que la balle
a frappé alors qu'il se retournait dans
le système pénal actuel le policier
était menacée directement lorsqu'il a
commencé à tirer et était donc en état
légitime défense la condition de 6000
tonalité était retenu dès que l'individu
a commencé à se trouver pour s'enfuir le
policier n'était plus en situation de
légitime défense et dans la réalité
toute la scène n'a duré qu'un instant
s'il est facile ensuite pour le
magistrat de la décortiquer quart de
seconde
art quart de seconde il était impossible
pour le policier dans le feu de l'action
d'arrêter son geste alors que l'individu
se retournait c'est pourquoi nous avons
proposé cette adaptation de la loi 2011
tirée de 167 du 14 mars 2011
d'orientation et de programmation pour
la performance de la sécurité intérieure
en modifiant les conditions d usage des
armes à feu pour les fonctionnaires de
police
nous y inscrire vos que les membres des
forces de l'ordre doivent avoir tiré sur
un individu armé qui refusent de déposer
son arme après des appels répétés de
haltes police cela leur évitera de
devoir attendre au risque de leur vie
d'être directement menacé par l'arm et
incitera les délinquants à déposer leurs
armes sur injonction de la police c'est
en effet la dimension préventive de ce
texte en élargissant le droit des
policiers à utiliser leur arme le
législateur on voit un signal à la
société et en particulier aux
délinquants ce signal dissuasif pour est
invité à plus de respect ou du moins a
plus de crainte des forces de l'ordre
s'est également bien sûr un signe envoyé
aux policiers qui travaillent dans ce
climat d'insécurité judiciaire climat
qui associée aux conditions de travail
extrêmement violente favorise
malheureusement les situations
d'exaspération et la possibilité de dire
à page
j'ai entendu les craintes selon
lesquelles ce texte ouvrirait la porte
aux violences policières pourtant les
gendarmes servent déjà dans la
délimitation de la légitime défense que
nous proposons d'ouvrir aujourd'hui aux
policiers et aucuns chiffres n'indiquent
un différentiel positif en matière de
faute professionnelle dans la
gendarmerie et bien mes chers collègues
sauf à différencier la confiance que
nous accordons aux policiers et aux
gendarmes
il n'y a aucune raison de différencier
les conditions d'exercice de leur
légitime défense cette confiance dépasse
les particularités des deux branches de
notre sécurité intérieure
et c'est bien dans cet état d'esprit que
louis et moi même avons décidé
d'harmoniser les conditions
d'utilisation des armes à feu chez les
policiers et chez les gendarmes
je souhaite éclairer à cet état d'esprit
en revenant sur un sondage qui a indiqué
récemment de l'armé incluant donc la
gendarmerie et l'institution dans
laquelle les jeunes de notre pays ont le
plus confiance avec 85% de réponses
positives la police ne bénéficie
malheureusement pas de la même image et
il est de notre devoir de responsables
politiques de tout faire pour améliorer
la légitimité et l'image des gardiens de
la paix il me semble que la légitimité
le respect et la confiance qu'accordent
les citoyens à une institution est à
l'image de la légitimité que l'état lui
donne encore une fois il ne s'agit pas
de délivrer une licence pour tuer aux
forces de l'ordre il s'agit de
rééquilibrer une situation qui fait
aujourd'hui peser sur notre police une
forme de soupçon permanent vous
conviendrez mais chaque collègue que nos
policiers ne tire pas sur les gens nus
avec plaisir ni avec excès de zèle et
dans une société centrée sur le confort
le moindre effort et le moindre
engagement nous devons nous incliner de
respect devant ceux qui font le choix de
cet engagement risqué sa vie pour
assurer la paie de tous et bien pourtant
mes chers collègues ces femmes et ces
hommes qui serait allée chaque matin
sans savoir s'ils rentreront chez eux le
soir sont quotidiennement méprisé
insulter agresser
lequel d'entre nous peut-il sérieusement
affirmer que la police fait toujours du
régner la terreur en france lequel
d'entre nous peut-il sérieusement
prétendre que l'insécurité est un
fantasme et qu'il n'y a pas de problèmes
de délinquance en france lequel d'entre
nous peut il nier l'évolution de la
violence et la nature des armes qui
circulent aujourd'hui dans certains
milieux mes chers collègues nous avons
pris acte lors de la discussion en
commission et un certain nombre d'entre
vous exprimer certaines inquiétudes
vis-à-vis de ce texte je dois vous dire
que je suis attristé par ces réticences
qui me semble en décalage avec la
réalité
refusé de renforcer le droit de nos
policiers à se défendre par méfiance
s'est renversé les choses et voir la
menace du côté des forces de l'ordre je
ne crois pas que l'on puisse aujourd'hui
estimé que la police abusent de
l'utilisation de ces armes mes chers
collègues nous avons tous en mémoire les
images de nos policiers se réfugiant
derrière dit oubliée sous les tirs de
fusil de chasse des émeutiers à
clichy-sous-bois en 2005
devant le sang-froid et la mesure de ses
agents je ne crois pas que l'on puisse
parler d'une police de cow boy comme le
disait louis vous savez un certain
nombre de co signataires de ce texte
m'ont dit vouloir soutenir une
proposition de bon sens je crois
effectivement qu'en donnant aux forces
de l'ordre les moyens de leur mission il
s'agit plus de bon sens que d'idéologie
il aurait d'ailleurs étaient à l'honneur
de notre haute assemblée de trouver et
le large majorité sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle je souhaite pour ma part que
cette question ne soit pas enterrée et
espère qu'elle trouvera bientôt une
réponse et un cadre adapté car si nous
négligeons ceux qui garantissent la paix
nous risquons tout simplement un jour de
la perdre je vous remercie